it was important for you to come up here
and explain to people that you don't
gotta sell drugs or play balls
none of that like this is my thing this
is my whole
testimony this is what i want everybody
to know you do the same energy that
these kids these grown men these women
any person
is putting into trying to play a sport
which the likely the likeliness of you
making it into impossible impossible you
know but you spend like you spend so
much money so much time so much effort
trying to be a basketball player trying
to be a football player trying to play
this play soccer play whatever you spend
so much time trying to be a rapper
trying to be a singer playing for versus
paying for studio time paying for
engineers traveling back and forth to
the studio
if you put that same energy into a
business whether it's you could put that
same energy into selling shoestrings
now i'm going to shoot now i'm going to
come every shoe convention selling every
person there my shoe strings you know
i'm making different shoe strings for
different days different holidays you
know if you put that same energy into
making a business you'll win